what does it mean a little cooler life
admit by your rule
nobody else's not mine because I'm
dancing how your mother's not the
[ __ ] world your vision of your life
by newer rules every [ __ ] day
who knew that purko life being Gary be
up in the office do red pepper water to
properly talk about ownership and
leverage 1800 sectors that out there
marriage
you
hi Gary hello how are you I'm super love
doing how are you oh wow
good way out there it is super wet out
there
buenas Dias how are you I've been told
from orientation you know you can grow
here in a vertical position you want to
go in part motor going so with like some
like advice you can give me a partner
email Steve Babcock the Babcock our
chief creative officer yeah I follow you
on Instagram so email him see see me
today I met with Gary telling him my
story told him about this
you lead creative here at Vayner and I'd
like 10 minutes with you to tell you
like what my passions are so that you
can create a blueprint of giving me the
best opportunity to being creative if
that's what you're looking to do yeah
it's literally like that simple you know
to make such fundamental ships it just
takes patience of opportunity you know
putting yourself in a position for the
opportunity and the opportunity then
presenting itself and so I think you
know sometimes that takes 18 months
sometimes that takes eight days great
I mean any but no me I'm in no hurry I
can feel it I can feel it that's the
answer that I can only appreciate
whoever is in place yep I feel like like
I said I told you I like to find it
there's so many different pots boiling
one yep and there's so many different
things to like yeah I don't I don't feel
the angst in you thank you you're
welcome you're welcome such a pleasure
have a great day thank you you too
yeah walked in here like my original
idea was they all not ask you if I can
pitch him something but honestly I don't
think that's really the best way for me
to do that what I realized was that the
best roommate this time Thomas valuable
is to ask I guess or someone's call when
I want to feel uncomfortable I don't
know what I'm doing because I think
that's way more important yeah because
I'm filled and I know that's what you
want from me yeah done okay absolutely I
mean look the most valuable thing I have
is kind well you you know it would have
been easier for me to say yes to $25,000
in seed capital than the answer of that
but look I think you know one of the
great ambitions I have a vaynermedia is
that whether somebody workshop for a
week and gets fired because we hate them
yeah or whether somebody works you up
for 74 years or everything in between
like a summer internship that they view
it as the best ROI that they could have
ever done and so that's why I say yes I
mean you know the answer sure I built
this with a few of my friends yep it's a
weird word so the 2017 book challenge I
love it
we're going to be ready for launch on
Friday I love it I love it I'll get it
out there and watch it on product runs
and we're putting on bells and whistles
I'll make sure people see it yeah so all
you know that's you as well my inbox is
open to you brother absolutely all you
million please what somebody please how
much you got it good to see you good
sees it I got you a little present
thank you there I'll take them sitting
it's the love tape Radio Raheem Buffett
dude that's awesome Italy yes I love
that man I do love that idea when they
would a lot of located anywhere so I'm
in the business of love hey super pro I
appreciate it but can answer free so 95%
of my time is all taken about
your secret yeah kind of like fellow
from that on like social media and
whatever you should just punt it yeah I
was gonna ask you content only 5% of
your time do something relax
punt it you can gain it back in five
minutes
yet you've got a task you've got an
agenda punt it where do you see
cryptocurrency affecting business in
general for you or whether it is I think
for like countries no I think crypto is
a real thing I haven't dug deep enough
to like kind of put my [ __ ] on the
record but the platform theory M that
the blockchain the thought of like legal
transactions happening on it yeah and
you know it's just very real you know
you can't stop technology you can
regulate it and slow it down but you
can't stop it
so intuitively I think it's a game
changing technology and but I haven't
dug deep enough to really over think it
or come up with smart strategies just
yet baby do you think that you would
want to build out things like the
electric skills and whatnot first when
you feel like get the tackle like all
kinds of new innovation no I
that's exactly right like the reason I'm
not looking at VR or crypto is like you
can only really focus and so for me
right now voice is the next half-decade
and I want to be great at it so that's
why I'm spending more time on that let's
say than the others you be a call soon
I go to miss channel can you I did will
manage that
what like value can you grant to like
fortune 500 companies or startups that
can help us like leverage what we're
trying to do we know from resolving
networking opportunities are so limited
some organization how can we as college
students bring leverage to the company
by asking the decision maker what the
[ __ ] they want
I believe the way winners win is by
going to other winners and basically
framing up hey I want a jam with you
however you want to say that I take in
any form somebody may want to take it in
a little more professional format right
I feel like I have an unbelievable
amount of knowledge of what's going on
in the 18 to 25 universe that has to be
impacting your business what can I do
with that information how do i
synthesize that into something that's
valuable to you hit me back literally on
linkedin literally on email literally on
diem or private message on social if you
just do that with Mark Cuban down to 337
people that you want to [ __ ] with six
answer how do you show them that like I
actually have networking to people that
I can actually meet with when they don't
know anything about your college or you
don't because you have no way to really
show it that because they don't have
time for you to show it I think you have
to just go with people who intuitively
just call like guess it's selling to the
sellable like don't look it but just
how'd you get this job it's of course
it's timing how many times did you try I
was first I guess just like building a
ship and then just DM DM DM the endgame
you off your games there I emailed you
dmg snapchatted you nothing yeah and
then eventually you respond to email and
see like the rock and I work here you
just ask you just ask the harder part is
offering on the hardest part is asking
with class the amount of people watching
this on YouTube right now that asked me
with no class it's all their value prop
it's all sticky things like I'll help
you buy the Jets it's all shtick like if
you don't answer this you'll regret it
like it's all posturing instead of
people your posturing YouTube I don't I
don't want posturing
I want value proposition whatever Justin
bid to make me sympathy Rock probably
looks something like I will work for
free for a year make you videos yeah
also make you better label here yeah but
it's still hard right like like last
week
Justin complained about D rocks
dictatorship and he's right like no
matter how like like do you understand
or maybe he's wrong the truth is it
doesn't really matter like it's eating
[ __ ] sounds great and be severely enough
anse he was like yeah when the thought
of like you saying to Mark Cuban or us
or like clever like Puff Daddy like it
sounds great and it's really
wait for the first month and then it
gets hard I know Matt it's still macro
great it get micro hard right and so
like right like like how long are you in
now right so what the things that's like
eight months in you know you start
having those hopes and thoughts of like
look I mean he wasn't filming daily be
eight months ago so there are winds and
they're big winds if you're older like
me you see it it's harder when you're
younger it's just [ __ ] facial and a
vision already so sorry finally brother
real quick let me just like let me use
this opportunity
nobody has patients ever it's a not a
millennial thing there's any six year
olds right now we touched a grandmother
she didn't have [ __ ] patients either
but humans don't have patients it's why
we reward the patient and talented with
the patient's like that now you always
say that right now the toilet very old
is your biggest high-risk high-reward
yeah this is the time where like I could
go either way if you said to me like I'm
gonna go and live in you know
Cambodia for a decade I was like I get
it like you'll never do it again like I
get it I get it isn't that sort of a
dense patience patience is waiting
overtime vanilla but it's patience to
what you want right like actually living
in Cambodia for ten years or Barcelona
for ten years and having fun is the
ultimate patience you're saying yourself
I'm going to start at thirty which means
that forty maybe I'll have some things
going for me actually I extract chilli
would argue that really having fun for
the first decade out of school is the
ultimate patience if you have ambition
to create you see what I mean yeah so
there's just a lot of versions of it it
just you got to make sure that your
actions map your mouth and your
ambitions stay on the same track and
actually know those things have to map
your actions yeah and what you're
[ __ ] saying and what you're doing
have to map so if you're like I'm going
to be [ __ ] the owner of the Jets miss
Annette and you're like working seven
hours a week and [ __ ] taking 19 years
of vacation that doesn't look the part
if you're saying look I just want to
have a balanced life and make a cup of
coin enough to like get through like get
through meaning like make 400,000
you can look NIDA fine they can make for
2000rs New York Lewicki if you're
talented enough developer leave it
there's a lot of ways to do this my
biggest thing is I don't work like me or
don't like like there's no right answer
there's only a right answer for you you
just have to make sure that your North
Star at all times and it changes at 22
and 31 and for look I'm about to take a
shitload of time off right that's not
where my mind was at 22 but it is at 41
your life and world change and you just
got to keep mapping to it and and
trading on it daily
[Music]
I like August you know just like that I
can feel everybody's off that makes me
feel comfortable you know how was your
weekend wow that's awesome
I genuinely believe over the next half
decade that this becomes common practice
if you guys go big like this and people
start extending commercials on Facebook
because it makes so much sense in
today's double screen environment and so
to me that and then leverage culture to
create a flame but to me it's all
reverse engineering the fail you know
I'm trying to create captain and coke
like what like I think we have 16
at-bats to create captain and coke
because that's how you can grow your
business and I think that should be the
number one agenda with an investment I
genuinely excited by the random idea
that it all falls apart tomorrow when
you can get there you have to fall in
love with the loss got it that to me is
the ultimate that's why I just sit like
that it's a great thing to fire you up
about because then it kind of you've
almost been eliminated everything yeah
because it's not about okay now I'm
ready to crush or jump now I'm ready to
crush this relationship now I'm ready to
crush the startup now I'm ready to crush
this job now I'm ready to crush thirty
it's the reverse which is live crushed
now let's just see how it plays out and
we're you know using a boxing reference
since you brought up shadow boxing how
what you are is your Mike Tyson right
now you're on the offense in such an
extreme I'm far more Pernell Whitaker
and obviously most people know it's
Mayweather now I'm a counter puncher
what would you say is I saw
be my age interested in silver I mean my
mind don't change constantly but you
stay to case everything but like what
would you advise to seize advantage of
that my age to go work at work work for
free or work for money every six months
on something different until your thirst
is quenched I don't think you guys
realize how wasteful you can be with all
your 20s in the what everybody thinks is
wasteful but for someone like you if you
believe that is you and you know
yourself well like if it's not just you
painting that as a romantic picture
because you don't want to make a
decision if that's really you well then
you should go and do different [ __ ] for
six month intervals forever until you
can't move from the thing you're doing
yet because then I think like there's a
lot of you know I'm going to do
something and I find myself loving it
and then I found myself just loving the
next day anyway
you can lighten up they might in like it
might be okay for you to do that forever
yes you know somebody might say that
you're schizophrenic or I would just
tell you you're self-aware I think the
biggest thing is wrapping your head
around like doing it your way and just
blocking out everything else and
creating a life where you don't need the
finances to like just like the biggest
reason people lock themselves in is they
get into a place where their lifestyle
requires a certain amount of income
which they can't then get somewhere else
by leaving the thing they're doing if
you're making a hundred thirteen
thousand dollars a year being of
something at a New York City office and
you're living $113,000 lifestyle it's
hard to go make fifty four thousand
being an art assistant my big thing is
to go to reverse like really really live
humbly in your 20s to allow you to do
all those things because then it may
unlock your the love of your life
creatively and and career-wise which
then will always lead to your biggest
economic opportunity or just life
opportunity even if the max of the
economics is 80,000 nobody at 90 years
old wish they made more money they all
just wish they were happier so what do
you got like ESL morning what would you
advise me to cold email every single
film person on earth until one of them
gives you a job just like that which
size of like really finally content any
Content just do that that's right like
literally you should email Steven
Spielberg and be like can I intern for
you for free I highly believe you'll not
get a response but I think you will
somewhere yeah and if just jet a Patel's
in the mood that day that's life and
then you go out there like sleep on
somebody's couch that you met on
Craigslist and then you wake up nine
months later and go I want to be I want
to live in Mexico make tequila and then
you DM every single and then you have
every single person on Instagram that's
a tequila count and say I want to work
for the words I want to work for free
get people's attention that matter yeah
because whether they want the free or it
speaks to a hunger and ambition it
always attracts an a player everybody
gets fancy and thinks they're worth
something because they [ __ ] went to
Harvard or Penn State or made sixty
videos on YouTube that did well
everybody thinks they deserve something
I at this point of my career believe I
deserve nothing
that's the fundamental mindset that's
the difference between the winners and
losers it's vas create a vlog every a
provocative on media on a tour bus and
there are California New Yorkers that
they yeah it is but it's not because we
just need one person
where's Jay can shake out there yeah the
out first mate have in there del hey Jay
they need to pump out on its own every
day right I know you will try mom you
wanted when is it from 1 to X the whole
month of October i-5
okay okay Jake it's a band
yeah good so you're interested because
we might have no coin flip now now you
got one okay do you want to spend the
entire month of October on a convenience
tour bus to pump out talk Dalia so the
vlog that Aaron is on the comedian and
hearing disabilities awareness sure
great
you too great Jake because I've known
you longer you get to call heads or
tails - can somebody please record this
villainous everybody all right what one
more time this is this is this is that
you got what tails all right tails never
fails is your theory here somebody's
going on a comedian tour bus for the
whole month of October heads
Justin's gone yeah just call finally the
contestant will set it up Kevin Hart
[Applause]
make you're good at ping-pong and then
Alan I just want to make sure you grow a
lot of now I want you to throw some
finance person do you think you're good
at ping pong Kenneth
oh yeah grab everyone okay now listen
listen listen Justin's in a roommate
Dustin versus Nate ping pong at this
place on 23rd and Justin's going to film
it for me I want to see a wall on
occasion
Nate important question have you ever
beaten me in tennis no no so what's our
balls right in your head I think I'm
like 60 nano 1311 no something like that
instead of like a we're like two and oh
we go from let's not everyone everyone
wants to think they're good at think
luckily right yeah but I've got plans I
get punch in the mouth I don't know all
I understand what you're trying to say
their data attractive it is more than
going with the quote yeah you didn't
realize it was subconscious I know that
look
I know you do but it was still your you
never had a method here enough eternium
I see ya
you know it's funny there's a lot of
talk what my fear is a young man's game
was this ah Defiant ones
did you watch off documentary yet you
know when when when Dre is like music
for young man's game what was
interesting it's interesting like I
really think a lot of 20 to 35 year olds
underestimate their pulse on society and
that's what this just reminded me of
most a lot of the ideas that kids have
are actually right they just don't know
how to make businesses they just don't
know you're the talent like I was 22 and
knew how to make businesses right so
you're right it's either the experience
or telling there's no different than
being a crafty vet or coming in the
league at 18 and being dominant it's one
of those two right
yeah or both like Vince Carter right
like and then that's why you have a 25
year career right that's it miss that's
my answer to that question
at the best making to the question let's
have this conversation right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
sipping my tea I don't say much I'm in
the zone drinking my cut Alice machine
mama I just gotta manage it now remember
when I copped champion sound I wasn't
fifth grade makes taste best friends
pinning me down became our gospel would
it make a fan of me now I know too much
that's why I was late too much the
problem raps made play too much way too
much
I don't really pray too much I never
liked to wade through much mama I know I
was never meant to make it on a
Southside mascara need thicker this and
cow huh rappers brought a particular
child mouth fly forth ma'am so you the
junk you would say how hot or that takes
[ __ ] tickle me now my best friend stick
of meanness or my ex girls figure me out
my new girls kicking me out
I don't care what you think of me now I
know mama
I don't think people so people don't
want to tell me things that are bad
because they think I'd be upset I'm the
reverse I only want to know what's bad
because I know I'm the quickest path to
fix and so like this sucks this sucks
listen it it can be exhausting and if
somebody just doing it because that's
their nature well they're going to lose
but if you're like if you're like this
is good like if it's if it's critical
thinking you know I want to hear it like
people think they're a tattle or they're
like a debbie downer like I just got
done telling Marcus everything's broken
here because I believe that but I also
know equally everything's working here
with a fastest-growing thing of our
nature in the market you know there's a
lot of good so like you know like what
are you into outside of work right right
music cool man videos all you do is that
right that's like your jams that my dad
he likes like that would become allergic
but I don't know if that's the fat
have you ever I got an idea for you
advice I gave a kid really work for and
I think you should DM every single
artist and just DM immune foliar like
you should write and what kind of music
you write it very widely and perform you
ever put any of it up know what I don't
like a little let me let me make let me
give you let me do something real nice
for you
you write and perform something and put
it on put it down I'll use it in my blog
they will get real exposure okay I
appreciate you're welcome dude hit me up
let's make this living and breathe you
know
[Music]
supposed to like see how a tall
operative sausage gets cut unbelievable
dream come true now maybe we live
together with everyone how's your day
going well busy what's not the news all
right that's the norm just ignored are
you doing the be angry tonight yeah you
know for myself I'm in Seattle my dream
one day is to be able to say I'm right
here come here right now and you get
free stuff to the fruits of that and I
get that the mucus some bleep AHA
basically it turns out
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 262 of the
askgaryvee show I'm pretty excited about
this Ryan holiday is in the house I know
that a lot of you are smuggest fans of
this man's work I've seen this man pop
up now for feels like about a half a
decade I like saying that sort of five
years I'm not sure why it's so crazy I
don't give a [ __ ] what Drake has to say
now I would watch every minute of the
three years before he became drink all
of it I would consume all of it
show me the day before it happened and
then you realize it's not a day the
biggest reason I'm doing dailyvee is
because guys YouTube it's not a day
before it's the whole thing it's just a
volume of work that shows you it wasn't
a moment it was the whole [ __ ] thing
the whole process I carry in my pocket
every day I carry a [ __ ] that just
says memento mori which is Latin it
means remember your debt right on the
back there's a quote from Marcus
Aurelius except the stoic and he wrote
to himself he says you can lead life
right now that should let that determine
what you do and say and think so this
could be the last it's the last show I'm
on in my life this could be the last
city I'm on in my life
this can be the last book I ever write
you know the last time I talked to my
life could be the last time and you got
to let that determine you got to let
that shape that should the thought of
your mortality and death in it and not
in a depressing way should shadow
everything that you do because it's the
only way to make sure you do it right
boy do I talk and death about death a
lot right right yeah I mean I mean a
funeral like oh yeah I believe in it the
most as you can probably know a little
bit like I love I'm glad you brought
that up so your three words you're going
to die yeah actually that should let you
cut out [ __ ] that should let you
decide how you're going to treat other
people and let yourself be treated and
if you determine the quality of the work
if it happens to everybody in a micro
it's called whether police lights go on
behind you you're scared shitless you
change your behavior then the car drives
by you right and then for like three
minutes you're like okay I'm going to go
55 now and then you know four minutes
later you're going 73 again right and
that's how I think people do it in life
like something bad happens to hear
something they see something and they're
like oh [ __ ] I'm going to live under the
mindset if you're gonna die like yeah
big see my thing it hit them for a day
but it's like you hear about a friend
who has cancer and you think like what
we hide you off ideas right so you do
have cancer you're gonna [ __ ] die
like around cancer you just don't you
just don't first off good lots of people
do your cancer study but those are
already in your lab right yeah but like
you do have a fatal diagnosis from a
doctor he just can't tell you in six
months or sixty years but more
definitely a hundred percent going to
die and it could be tomorrow so what are
you going to do with that information I
believe in at the most my man blurry
perfect guys one life baby one life do
something about it please please use
this video to do something about it
thank you run and take care of some I
hope you enjoyed it okay care thank you
that was the sculpt in Boston but I was
living back in Miami was doing the
travel life for work again at it I mean
curious actually how many miles you did
last year budgets you will do that with
Tyler
do we have any feel of how many miles I
do a year miles come on now we did like
a hundred sixty-five Fletcher who got it
oh thanks shorter is plenty here right
so yeah being able to keep us caught a
lot of [ __ ] flight my big thing
Mike if you really want the real hack my
big hack is my just think we're letting
things never see the day of light at
scale that in the like that's today
there was 11 piece of content that are
rip [ __ ] bucket winners no prayer no
people never be seen will not be seen
you know you know I've said this a
million times original there's all we
talk about at this point me indie rock
there's fourth there I met seven people
[ __ ] interns today there's four
phenomenal [ __ ] podcasts of advice
that will kill we have no prayer of any
of them seeing the daylight and like six
unbelievable clips that are over a
million organic reach no prayer and
eleven quotes no prayer just we have no
we have no system for capturing the
sawdust which is like why would you hang
there and do not like we're going to
happen that's the number one act but
listen that's fine when I'm here what is
it me another [ __ ] person now that we
travel with like who's just there to cap
to produce maybe maybe that's what maybe
that's why there's producers I don't
know but I know one thing every day we
are missing out on thirteen things that
never become real and so what happens is
my facebook and my podcast is is to me
scale versus all the freshness that
comes out daily and that's that and that
system will work unlike Colin where he
needs me for the long-form content like
the clips and like the transcriptions
and like the podcast original it should
be that's where we have to hack and
honestly
like even more than ever before right
this second I think maybe it is the
producer and like like I just just too
much like I know what happened today and
it's 15 really good things and I'm going
to get one that's just stupid
that's just not achieving the
infrastructure we have so I don't know
what everybody takes away from that but
we need to figure that out you take how
many meetings do I have today how many
did I have to write 40 total alright
guys 7 656 p.m. or we've got 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 more meetings to go it's been a
pretty active day you learn something
tonight Russell yep what yeah and now
you're inside hey you do that you got
already anyway that's the little youtube
update the YouTube 655 656 p.m. update
let's make this a thing let's always
update you - that's 656 on the way too
dirty lemon event
Phil and I made investment in that
company direct consumer CPG brand them
do a guest bartending I just thought
that I don't have to bartend which is
huge but lots of high fives and selfies
and answering business questions which
is fine by me exactly how I like it so
hope I see you guys it's raining here in
New York so hopefully comfortable shop
so are we gonna dance in Delhi I need
your help
I feel anyway so we gonna dance anyway
you know to demo anyway so he's working
for me to live a fuller life
by your rule nobody else's not mine
because I'm fancying how your mother's
not the [ __ ] world your vision of
your life by newer rules every [ __ ]
day to new HEPA polite no [ __ ] Gary
Vee it's so great to meet you
why don't you try not to tell my work
I'm probably gonna hire but I don't give
a [ __ ] questions I wanted to see you and
I have to make a hat beg you my mom I'm
a rapper I got my first home on iTunes
right now it's just got all the
streaming services it's purple
afterparty my content is amazing I'm
going to do it for with my taxes and
everything like images Oh sick I'm
networking every day my dream is to be
on Gary Vee or one of the blog's I saw a
bug and gets fired at my job I had to
fire oh my [ __ ] god
[ __ ] man getting my job get my gun
he's your son Dario he appreciated
decides that I can you believe you're
doing this sense that you think I should
do
- give me upper hand more more song yeah
p.m. amor people okay God watch me like
every day just like my comment when I
wrote when you are with Nipsey Hussle
yep and I was like [ __ ] great minds
do it you're one of the people that
really got me motivated so safe I'm
season when I [ __ ] love go out it's
really appreciated because they come in
mother
connect with Justin I'm from the Midwest
yep yep yep
can they improve the marketing
easy
what's the zip code of your small town I
for seven zero three five four seven
zero great
daddy so when you click this dood post
business in that town you click them you
got 1500 people you hit the CM and and
you just literally fit him for a money
it was important to say yo when you
tried to build a relationship like I
just did literally I just type in the
zip code right yes he's - girl fight
she's got 800 to follow Christ thank you
so you can use it right and so like I'll
give you a normal one right don't shoot
1,500 bucks literally cleared it rigid
being a [ __ ] practitioner life that's
the [ __ ] game when you can answer
questions right on the [ __ ] spot I'm
Howard sharpie on I just put a plain
couple I'm sorry
before I woke up my god-given New York
type of flying goober that was my
Vitamix 500gr
got here let's do the pay off [ __ ]
made it I made it we made it turns on we
made it oh yeah I was like give me like
a personal touch your biggest one for
biggest aww I got it my man I'm going to
be real [ __ ] simple I'm going to make
this real simple what if today was the
last day you woke up what are you gonna
do about it
don't do that
retrieving a podcast we get Natalie yeah
bio Hannah is that yes but I could
really like you to help pick your brain
on I've had launches I got some pretty
big guests like lined up for it it's all
get it's all guests and it's you being
on guests on others and it's Facebook
Ads
driving to the podcast and it's
influencer marketing defent yes
you being a get facebook at the
influences on Instagram it's a wrap now
so do it right like that's the product
now how good are you at asking 8,000
people to be on their show they're gonna
see man how you been been good and then
private right speaking this today and
just last week primarily I see it
consistently consistently I see you
driving out there yeah okay thanks for
coming by
I feels like women I'm not going to
magicial is coming you coming out to do
that good good
[Music]
my manager today
[Music]
could you tell on passed away about a
straw Andre Andre lucious shoeshine shop
which is rather strong report a
patient's baby
[Music]
after all those things I said
I'm glad I have no reason I'm glad
and keep hustling baby could've [ __ ]
totally I could have you changed your
mind
yeah I just look around [ __ ] around
those pretty good cement real pleasure
now you know email go anyway we gone
additionally I know how to build on
anyway so we gonna dance anyway you know
the devil anyway so we gonna dance
anyway I think we can I can do selfie
from here on out wrapped up a long
goddamn day seven eight more meetings
another thirty three p.m. solid [ __ ]
day technical description come over to
get through a letter way you walk you
have to add it to me and big waving like
the other Malibu there's no order sugar
cocoa down to the same with the breath
like a local maybe you will work is so
hard approach